[Music]
this is what happens when you get to the
limits of what any normal person would
want in a phone
and then just blow right past it
[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here this is the rog
phone 5
ultimate edition
so there is no rg phone 4 for the same
reason there was no one plus 4 4 is an
unlucky number in some parts of asia so
we've skipped right to five and this
phone is
every bit as ridiculous as it looks it's
kind of funny they've actually sort of
been toning down the gamer phone
aesthetic over the years
but they have not been toning down how
ridiculous the actual phone is so gaming
phones when they were starting out were
never supposed to be reasonable you know
they're huge phones with pretty striking
designs rgb lights and the absolute
bleeding edge maximum specs available
and so the rog phone has been at the
forefront of that for a while and this
new one
definitely takes it even further so
first of all it's still got all the same
big number fundamentals from before it
is a massive phone it's got a gigantic
6.8 inch display 144hz ammo led a
snapdragon triple eight which while it's
not a plus version like they typically
launch the phone with it is absolutely
the latest and greatest right now still
has a massive
6000 milliamp hour battery half a
terabyte of ufs 3.1 and still has a huge
pair of stereo front-facing speakers
that get louder than any other phone
i've tested in a long time but now on
top of all that there's a lot of new
there's a surprising amount of upgrades
actually first of all you've probably
noticed this back it's a matte white
kind of a pearl like finish with blue
accents it's not the grippiest thing in
the world but it does reject
fingerprints really well and overall the
looks not too crazy it's still
unmistakably an rog phone with those
slanted lines and they just love
printing text all over the phone so
republic of gamer's logo the number five
for rog phone five the quad bear camera
text and at the top it says for those
who dare for some reason they love that
text
but i do think the sim card tray in blue
is a super nice touch and while the huge
white phone still does stand out i do
feel like the whole gamer phone
aesthetic is maturing a little bit from
just like rainbow puke now right in the
middle and you might have caught that
there is still a little bit of a glossy
piece right there and you might be
wondering what that is
that is another screen on the back of
this phone so it's called rog vision so
there's this little inch and a half
black and white screen that can display
different kinds of information
the settings for it here are in asus's
armory crate app instead of in the
settings app but once you dive in here
you can turn the screen on and off and
then choose what the screen lights up
for so you can see it lights up when the
phone's screen is on it lights up when
the phone is charging it even lights up
when you receive a phone call and then
for each of these scenarios you can
actually go in and customize the exact
animations that play in each scenario to
the point where you can actually create
new animations and import images that
you want to use
and make new animations for yourself
it's crazy now this is how i got the
mkbhd
text animation here playing on the back
of my phone anytime my screen is on it's
even orientation sensitive
i know it's it's extra there's no other
phone that does this and that's probably
for reason but hey if you're gonna go
niche you might as well go all the way
down the customization rabbit hole and
asus has like really committed to
something unique here so okay there's no
doubt they've leveled up the aesthetics
it definitely still looks like a gamer
phone but asus didn't just stop at the
aesthetics so that's 6 000 milliamp hour
battery i mentioned the one that won it
the smartphone award for battery last
year it's upgraded that to a fast
charging system inside thanks to two
things this really beefy heavy 65 watt
charging brake that comes in the box and
the new dual battery system inside so
it's actually now a pair of 3000
milliamp hour batteries that charge in
parallel so this is the same concept
that oneplus was using with the 8t two
smaller batteries in parallel charge
faster than one huge one so now it's a
massive best-in-class battery that also
charges really fast roughly zero to
seventy-five percent in around half an
hour which is plenty now that's already
great that's already i get a day and a
half of completely carefree use out of
this phone at 144 hertz which is crazy
and if you want to take it easy set it
to auto mode
those numbers start to get kind of
ridiculous at 60 hertz it's easily two
days but the other thing to think about
with a fast charging system like this is
you still want to think about battery
health
long term and that's also something asus
is thinking about so they've built in a
bunch of different battery charging
adjustments to address that so there's
now steady charging which charges slower
for better battery health there's
scheduled charging so you can reduce the
time that the battery is full and not in
use so basically it slow charges
overnight and then finishes up to 100
when it's time to get up and you can set
that to finish charging depending on
when your scheduled alarm is that is
dope and you can also manually set a
charging upper limit to just straight up
limit your max charge to 80 or 90 and
then on top of that there's something
called bypass mode which is such it's
such a gamer specific thing but when
you're in this mode you plug in the
phone let's say you're gaming it
bypasses charging the battery and just
puts the power straight into the system
so that you're not heating up the
battery as you're charging because
you're not charging and you're not
cycling the battery so it's just going
straight into the actual system
who would have thought it's a great idea
so i'm clearly very impressed with the
battery as you can probably tell
but there's more
first of all they brought the headphone
jack back is this the first phone that
i've seen that's ditched the headphone
jack with one year's upgrade and then
brought it back the next year
i think so i think so they moved it from
the phone in the rog phone 3 to the fan
accessory through usb last year
now it's back in the phone and not only
is the headphone jack back but there's a
dac behind it and there's a whole audio
wizard built into the software that lets
you drag 10 different frequency response
sliders and change the audio in a crazy
way like that's just that's approaching
too much customization at this point
it's awesome they've also technically
leveled up the performance and the specs
of the phone here too so imagine all the
highest end specs possible that can fit
in the phone snapdragon 8 chip check
half a terabyte of the fastest ufs 3.1
storage check
18 gigs of ram on this highest end
version
check 144hz maximum refresh rate on the
display with a 300 hertz touch sample
rate check this is about as consistently
smooth of a phone as you'll get to see
like 18 gigs of ram
in a phone is this some kind of joke
like
clearly i'm not the biggest gamer i
don't really play games on my phone like
that so i'm playing games to test this
and it's obviously very responsive but
the performance difference between this
and something like a galaxy s 21
something with maybe 12 gigs of ram
to be fair
is pretty small so this is like i
mentioned at the beginning the rog phone
5 ultimate edition which is the highest
end in a new lineup of phones which i'll
get to in a minute but
this has 18 gigs and then the rest of
the lineup gets up to 16 gigs so i feel
like they added
the extra two gigs of ram for this phone
just for i mean it's gaming it's
bragging rights yes it's technically
better but
i feel like they just want to be able to
say they had the most ram in any phone
which they can say now which is kind of
sad because you can't actually pin apps
into ram like you can on like samsung
and oneplus phones would be nice to add
on a phone like this right now one thing
you probably didn't expect to be so good
about a gaming phone
is the cameras
because they're usually pretty bad so
this is an area where i was actually
pleasantly surprised by rog phone five
it has some decent cameras it's a triple
camera set back here a 64 megapixel
primary 13 megapixel ultra wide and a 5
megapixel macro camera
and i wasn't expecting much like i said
but the more photos i took with this
primary camera the more impressed i was
this thing makes some nice detailed
pretty confident and contrasty photos
it's the style that reminds me of the
pixel it's not quite pixel level but it
reminds me a lot of the zenfone also by
asus which did win the blind smartphone
camera test we did last year so this
phone did a really good job maybe just a
tiny bit aggressive with the hdr
sometimes and i've noticed it's a little
bit slow to focus on closer up objects
so you can miss focus a bit
but it's better than i expected from a
gaming phone the ultra wide is
definitely weaker and softer per usual
and the macro it works but the minimum
focus distance isn't as close as i'd
expected from a macro and the selfie
camera is wildly inconsistent with
exposure so it's fine but you know even
in the same room with back to back
selfies i could get like totally
different shots like i know you're
probably not getting this phone just for
the cameras but it's it's nice that it's
not super disappointing so that's
i would give it like a b minus in the
grand world of smartphone cameras it's a
b minus it's not bad the reason you
would buy a phone like this is because
of the power you get in the palm of your
hands and the ridiculous level of
customization possible you saw the audio
customization behind the headphone jack
you already saw the display on the back
of this phone acting like a notification
led on steroids even though this phone
already has a notification led but then
there's also these performance profiles
and the armory crate that let you
quickly flip over into a gaming mode or
an everyday use mode or a battery saver
mode and then all the custom settings
that go with it
and there's even the custom buttons did
you even remember the custom buttons on
this phone it's kind of a big deal
there's a pair of the shoulder triggers
called air triggers that are mappable
and in addition there's a second set of
back buttons
and from my experience they're not as
sensitive but they do work by just kind
of sliding your finger over them
honestly i don't even know what games i
would play that are serious enough to
take advantage of these but if you do
that's two more extra buttons on the
back of this phone so you don't have to
cover that precious screen real estate
with your fingers it's crazy stuff and
on top of all of that like i said it
feels like uh like like a sports car
that you can also drive on the daily
and i say that because zen ui feels
pretty close to stock android like
they've built a lot of the features
directly into the settings without
turning it into some blinged out
over-the-top gamer-y look i mean it can
be that when you want it to but if
you're not it's a very usable daily
phone now i've said a lot of good things
in the past however many minutes this
has been so far
now if you're thinking well what's the
catch what are the bad parts of this
phone there's got to be stuff that's not
perfect
and there is definitely
i would say a bunch of it adds up to
feeling a little bit less premium than
the highest end phones in this price
bracket and maybe that's because i've
just used some of the other ones
recently
but there's some stuff to note like the
vibration motor and the haptics aren't
great at all and in a gaming phone
actually i would expect this to be a
pretty heavy focus like having great
haptics and a gaming phone for immersion
sake would feel really cool
this is maybe one notch better than the
classic old vibration motors of the past
it's nowhere near the best doesn't feel
very precise or tight at all the
fingerprint reader is slow like there's
no way around it i guess if i'm sticking
with my car analogy that would be like
taking a long time to turn on
i don't know it just gets annoying after
a while when it is slow to unlock a lot
and then the display while it is super
responsive we know the 144 hertz is
great it's still slightly below a1
quality like there's a bit of the
telltale rainbowing when you're off axis
and while the max brightness did improve
it can't still get washed out in harsh
sun
there's no wireless charging call
quality is definitely not that great
and the rubber plug on the side usb
ports falls out really easily and they
definitely know this because they
included two extra ones in the box but
i'm convinced i'm gonna lose them all
and also fun fact we did manage to kill
this phone to zero percent battery and
when we did it wouldn't charge back up
until we plugged it in the side usb port
which asus tells us is the primary usb
port asus also tells us that this will
be fixed with an upcoming software
update so it's not perfect like there's
there's definitely stuff that's quirky
about it but the thing is i think the
easy complaint about a phone like this
is that is a giant
clunky form factor with like kind of
thick bezels why wouldn't you go closer
to the edge and do a hole punch but on a
gaming phone
if the idea is to be here all the time
and not interrupt your view with a hole
punch then having a little extra on the
side to hold it and having huge
front-facing stereo speakers
is a trade-off that i think makes a lot
of sense so overall this is a really fun
ridiculous phone so now that you've made
it all the way to the end of this video
i'm assuming you have like at least a
tiny little bit of interest in buying
this right
so this phone this rog 5 ultimate
edition highest 10 spec is
uh
1299
euros there's a little bit of conversion
math depending on where you are in the
world
but that's expensive now this ultimate
edition includes the phone and also this
incredibly extra ar unboxing experience
that the phone boots into the first time
you set it up it's pretty cool and
there's a fan accessory and there's some
asus gamery swag like a hat there is
like i mentioned though a lineup so this
is the ultimate the highest end version
12.99 then there is a rog phone 5 pro
for 11.99 and there's this guy which is
just the standard rog phone 5 which
starts at 7.99
big difference uh it skips the screen on
the back and it doesn't have the two
touch sensitive back buttons and it
starts at eight gigs of ram and 128 gigs
of storage and so if you're thinking
about getting one
the base version i feel like is the most
reasonable and then i think when you
upgrade for an extra 100 euro that first
upgrade is pretty nice double the
storage bump up your ram but then this
spec right here i think is a little
crazy a hundred extra dollars for just
four more gigs of ram which i don't know
i feel like that's not the move but then
the price only goes up from here as you
upgrade further in the lineup but hey
you know what they say you gotta pay to
play
do they actually say that i don't know
i'm just look i only play among us on my
phone i feel like at this point there
are people who are more squarely in the
target demographic who are thinking
about shooter games first person
whatever other games you play that
require multiple custom buttons
this is a phone that's going to be
really fun for that but let me know what
you think are you the type
to go all out on a crazy customized
gaming phone like this with a screen on
the back the whole deal let me know in
the comments section below also the
wallpaper i'll link below as i always do
and yes by the way we do have long
sleeve shirts in the merch store shop
item kbht.com it's good stuff
either way that's been it thanks for
watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]